We saw generator expressions and functions in Unit 2,
but some people in the forums still seemed a bit confused.
Don't worry. This is understandable.
The generator is an entirely new object, and it can be confusing.
In the next few videos, we're going to answer three questions.
How do we use generators? I think this is actually an easier question to answer than the second.
What is a generator expression/function/object?
We'll also talk about when and why do we use generators?
Let's start with a problem.
We want to compute the sum of the squares of the integers from 1 to 1 million.
That would be 1 + 4 + 9--and I probably shouldn't write all of these out.
The question is how would you do this?
If you came from CS101, your answer is probably to start with a function.
Maybe your function would have looked something like this
where we make an empty list, append all of the squares to that list,
and then return the sum of that list.
Then you would have called your function with an argument of 1 million,
and you would've gotten your answer.
First let me say this is a find solution. It gets the job done, but it has some problems.
Keeping in mind that we just want to make this calculation once,
what do you think is the biggest problem with this solution.
Do you think it's messy, and it unnecessary clutters up the program?
Do you think it uses memory when it doesn't really have to?
Do you think it runs to slowly? Or do you think the code doesn't work?
You may have several problems with this, so it's somewhat subjective.
Just choose whatever you think is the biggest problem.